para analizar este inicio de turle de la
bienvenida Tatiana Rodríguez periodista
del diario asco Colombia Tatiana
bienvenida Hola Juan buenas noches un
placer como siempre estar acá y hablando
Ya del tour por fin llegó muy pronto
esta victoria de Víctor la fe y la
primera Victoria para Francia en este
Tour de Francia él ya lo vimos ayer
codearse con bingle en el último en el
último Puerto del día está demostrando
que tiene un buen estado de forma en
este inicio del tour sí Juan Este es un
ciclista que ya ha estado varios años en
el cofidis siete años exactamente es el
uno de los gregarios por excelencia de
guilón martamen el equipo francés y hoy
sorprendió tanto a sus compañeros como a
sus directores deportivos con esa
decisión que toma la anticipación Pues
en la etapa en los últimos metros y
ganándole al máximo favorito del día de
hoy que era el corredor del Jumbo guated
fue una sorpresa para todos incluso para
su equipo el mismo lo reconoció al final
Yo creo que es un corredor que
no es tan joven Digamos como como lo
veníamos viendo algunos corredores
jóvenes pero sí comenzó muy bien el Tour
de Francia comenzó siendo digamos la
distinción con respecto a sus otros
compatriotas
la gente estaba digamos muy pendiente o
todavía lo está de de lo que pueden
hacer David gaudú de lo que puede hacer
romain bardet que en este momento Pues
están en los primeros 25 en lugares de
la clasificación general incluso de lo
que puede hacer Juliana la philippe que
no comenzó muy bien el Tour de Francia
pero el que se ha destacado ha sido la
fe que como usted lo dijo ahorita en los
titulares hace 15 años el cofidis no
tenía un triunfo con el último de
silvanchabanel y ahora con este francés
un poco desconocido para muchos pues
está consiguiéndolo de nuevo ha llovido
mucho desde entonces la fe que hizo la
que ha intentado muchas veces Fernando
Gabriel esta temporada atacar de lejos y
nunca le ha salido le salió hoy a la
vamos a cambiar de tema hablemos un poco
de las estrategias que hemos visto en
estas dos primeras etapas del Tour de
Francia un equipo de pogachar que ha
intentado llevar un poco el peso de la
carrera y quizás un Jumbo un poco más
conservador de hecho quizás pecaron de
exceso de confianza Precisamente en el
remate de la etapa de hoy
sí pareciera que fuera conservador no un
poco conservador el Jumbo misma yo lo
que creo Es que luae está aprovechando
estas primeras etapas antes de la
montaña para digamos arañar o el
máximo de bonificaciones posibles para
cuando llegue el tiempo de la del grueso
de la competencia y de la alta montaña
Yo creo que es así Creo que lo estamos
viendo así Creo que los dos equipos son
muy buenos tanto tanto el Jumbo como el
uae Y bueno pues lo que está haciendo el
uae es lo que quisiéramos ver del
ciclismo siempre no de no solamente en
estas etapas sino en todas el espíritu
de taipo gacha es imbatible es Es un
ciclista muy bueno
pero yo creo que todas las veces en las
que podáchara ha intentado atacar o ha
hecho esos ataques yo unas binglegard lo
ha seguido no le ha cerrado el hueco lo
ha perseguido todo el tiempo incluso
hubo dos veces ya en las dos primeras
etapas en las que apodachar le dice que
lo ayude y venga le dice no se ha negado
rotundamente hacerlo creo que como le
digo los dos equipos son muy buenos y lo
que vamos a ver de ahora en adelante
pues va a ser esa esa medida de fuerzas
no entre los dos creo que tiene un poco
más de mejores gregarios el Jumbo isma
en este momento que que luae y además el
uae tiene un colíder no que es Adam
yates que también lo vamos a ver ahí
dando la pelea Y seguramente
haciéndole también el contrapeso en lo
que falta del tour también al ataque lo
hemos visto muy contento está muy feliz
ya lo vimos bailar en este Tour de
Francia se nota que tiene buen ánimo en
esta carrera
11 segundos es la diferencia entre ya y
llevamos ya dos etapas de tour vamos a
hablar de los latinoamericanos el mejor
latinoamericano en esta carrera lo
comentábamos egan Bernal que se mantiene
ahí en el lote de Los favoritos un
corredor que apenas ha disfrutado 4
Apenas ha terminado cuatro carreras este
año y recordemos que hace año y medio
Por poco y pierde la vida buen
rendimiento el de egan sí ha sido un
buen rendimiento el de egan en la
conferencia de prensa previa al Tour de
Francia dijo que para el Tour de Francia
se sentía mejor de lo que se sintió en
el criterio en el doppyne que fue la
última carrera que hizo antes de
comenzar el Tour de Francia y es lo que
ha venido demostrando no la curva de
rendimiento de egan va en ascenso y es
lo que hemos visto en estas dos etapas
en las que ha estado pegado a Los
favoritos ha perdido el menor tiempo
posible es lo que hemos visto después de
Carlos Rodríguez es el mejor ciclista de
su equipo de lineos grenadiers Sin
embargo yo creo Juan que que esto de
egan a pesar de que es muy esperanzador
Porque además son etapas en las que
digamos no es alta montaña que es lo que
lo caracteriza Y es para sus cualidades
como ciclista creo que hay que tener un
poco de calma Sí un poco de prudencia
esperar digamos Cómo va a evolucionar el
cuerpo y el físico y las piernas de egan
cuando llegue la alta montaña y cuando
llegue la contrarreloj y las etapas que
van a ser definitivas en el Tour yo creo
que
una llegada a París creo que va a ser lo
mejor para egan ya sería un triunfo
ahora si va a luchar por un top 10 o de
pronto por el triunfo de una etapa creo
que es para celebrarlo en grande
Totalmente de acuerdo también a
Rodríguez periodista del diario